what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into spider gedan
now here's the thing this is edgewood
spider again alright for those people
who are familiar with spider-verse bear
with me for a second because this is
kind of a repeat but for those people
who are new to all this
spider verse was a story originally
written by Dan Slott and it was
literally just like this big multiversal
crossover of the spider man dealing with
like the inheritors more alone and
different things like that if you don't
know who they are not a great big huge
deal um I have videos on spider-verse
you're welcome to go check those out and
get a get a better understanding of it
but it was one of those things where it
was it kind of took place like between
two issues of superior spider-man it was
kind of weird but it was a really really
popular story when it came out now what
this does is it kind of builds on that
and it brings back a lot of characters
that were already familiar with but edge
of spider-verse was the lead up to
spider verse and edge of spider-verse
told stories of like all these different
versions of spider-man that we'd never
seen or heard of before that was where
spider twin was introduced I'm pretty
sure edge of spider-verse um that's
where you got like spider hint well
spider him and been around for a while
I'm pretty sure that's like that's where
spider-ham kind of made his return for
the modern reader Peter porker
spider-ham is amazing I'm so excited to
see him in edge of spider I'm sorry into
the spider verse spider him is so cool I
love the character spider-ham but one of
the characters that was introduced was
spider punk was punk-rock spider-man of
course this is on earth 1 3 8 and that's
why spider again it is standalone you
don't really have to have red spider
verse in order to understand it but it
doesn't hurt because a lot of these
characters are making their return so we
don't really get origins here instead I
mean we can call it an origin in so far
as like I'll explain it in this video ah
but it is kind of a cool thing here
because in this version and in the edge
of spider-verse it focused more on the
original characters and it didn't I
guess the orders of the characters
didn't really focus on like their
greater universes what this does is it
focuses on the unit on the light like
the greater expanse of spider pump
things like Eric Masterson for example
with thunderstruck now this is kind of
cool because this brings back
thunderstruck from the 1990s those guys
you don't know Thunderstrike eric
Masterson was yet another person to
become Thor there's been like three or
four people who became Thor over the
course of marvel's publication history
on but eric Masterson was like an like
an architect or a construction worker or
something like that who ended up getting
the powers of Thor and then of course
that's the version of Thor you saw
during the events of Infinity Gauntlet
it wasn't actually Donald Blake Odinson
I mean I guess it was but not directly
it's kind of a weird situation but in
this universe he is essentially just
like a guy who causes problems up but
the whole basis behind spider Punk's
universe is it as a
Rock universe so they're all like
anti-establishment so while he's
basically like like given the business
to to Thunderstrike suddenly he's met by
the arrival of like Cana Conqueror from
the future of this universe and in the
future of this universe specifically in
the year 2099 it kind of changes things
and switches things around and what I
mean by that is in the year 2099 in the
main Marvel Universe you have alchemax
that runs the show alchemax is basically
like this really shoddy organization
they're kind of like rocks on but not as
bad I guess if you could say such a
thing if you don't know what Roxxon Oil
is do like the most corrupt company in
the entirety of the Marvel Universe they
had their hands on everything but Alka
match was equally bad and you had Niguel
O'Hara spider-man 2099 who fought
against alchemax you know during during
that time but with regards to this
spider punk universe where alchemax was
kind of the antithesis to spider-man
which was like corporate greed and
corruption and different things like
that in this universe King it
incorporated basically is the antithesis
to spider punk it's like corporate you
know money-making and marketing and all
kinds of stuff um it's basically like
Hollywood run amok and it's kind of cool
because like it literally brings him
directly into conflict with spider punk
because what is up happening is they as
king basically says hey look spider Punk
I know you're like anti-establishment
you're like angsty you know and like
every fifteen-year-old kid ever but in
the future like we turn you in a
merchandise man like we market you man
like we've got TV shows the comics don't
make as much as the movies but the
movies manly this what do you think and
spider punk is pissed because he's like
I'm anti-establishment man I'm so
misunderstood by the world like it like
no one you you can't you can't be like
me man like I'm outside of your system
happy birthday to the ground if you guys
don't know what that means then you guys
are missing out on like one of the best
things ever dude I think I'm not part of
your system
oh god SNL how I miss you when you were
good well not as good as during the
nineties Will Ferrell but so it's still
pretty good
like still pretty decent anyway so uh so
don't know less it turns me kind of a
cool fight because what is up happening
is like this future King summons like
all these little mini spider guys that
basically attack attack this version
Spider Man actually this is kind of an
important thing too this is not Peter
Parker this is Hobie Brown so that's one
thing to bear in mind here is it's not
Peter Parker from a punk rock universe
not only that you also have like captain
captain anarchy
which is kind of interesting I guess it
kind of makes sense you know it's not
really Hampton America's Campton captain
anti
captain anarchy sounds better than
captain anti-establishment I guess it
just rolls off the tongue better I don't
really know but like you essentially end
up having like these let the negative
I'm sorry the the annihilation away from
the negative zone that pours into this
universe now this is when things get
kind of interesting honestly I'm a bit
of a stickler when it comes to like
continuity even in like crazy what-if
stories and so on and so when I saw this
I was like yeah but there's only like
one negative zone
so like the annihilate Way annihilation
way should be the same across like all
the universes but at the end of the day
I kind of had to sit back and say you
know what Rob you can't take this story
too seriously because it's not meant to
be taken seriously so just shut the hell
up and enjoy the ride that's basically
what I had to tell myself and it's
entertaining it's it's really really
cool because like with spider punk come
like all these little spider guys that
are trying to attack a little spider
blimps is what I'm gonna call them
they're like little little what is it
chibi spider-man is that what you guys
call them in the the anime the Japanese
cartoon things a little like mini
versions of people I'm not really
familiar with it I don't really know I
know there are some people who were part
of like the Japanese cartoon community
who were just like you know I have a
hard time differentiating between the
two like I always kind of saw them as
similar but again like that's outside of
my wheelhouse so yeah I'm not really
huge well except for Dragon Ball Dragon
Ball was like the best anime ever um
okay what we'll call them anime instead
of like Japanese cartoons you know I
know people are just like just give in
Rob just stop resisting Rob just call
them animes wrong Dragon Ball was the
best so anyway um so so I'm gonna get so
much so much anger so much vitriol you
know I'm not gonna read the comments for
this video like I'm not I'm not gonna
read the comic I'm just gonna ignore the
comments of this video I'm gonna get so
much hate from the from the whole like
anime community oh god man like it's
it's it's it's gonna be kind of bonkers
I don't know why I think that's funny it
is a little bit funny but still like how
many of you guys ever saw filthy Frank's
video on weeaboos which apparently are
people who think they're Japanese think
they're like they're from Japan it was
kind of funny here's like Weaver's go to
Japan and they'd be like where's the
subtitles I'm sorry we're totally off
topic here okay back on topic Gordon do
not cut that out back on topic okay so
uh so here's a cool thing so what is it
happening here is you end up having
spider Punk who goes to captain Anarchy
and Captain anarchies whole thing is I
need the tape I need the tape so like
set the atom bomb off and to have him do
his thing and it's kind of ambiguous at
first because it's kind like okay what
does the tape have to do with anything
as
ultimately once he accesses the tape he
ends up racing off to what really has
captain anarchy hold off you know King
from 29 or whatever and then races off
to see like Bruce Banner punk rock Bruce
Banner and it's like okay this is kind
of cool actually we'd like the mohawk
and everything you know in like punk
rock salt salt lake or whatever with
Salt Lake City or whatever that was like
um what is it Salt Lake City Punk is
that the movie that it was back in the
day with like the punk rock community
and so on and so forth I don't know they
were all just sitting around listening
to sublime talking about how everybody's
like establishment now and so they were
hipsters before they were hipsters and
so like like he ends up showing up here
and then basically talks directly with
with like Bruce banners like look man
like we kind of have to work together
here like I know you don't wanna do this
again but like we've fought together a
ton of times and we face up against a
bunch of enemies a ton of times and this
is a situation where I could
legitimately die so either you're in my
corner or you're not and if you're not
then fine I'll just go fight myself and
so we're we're hoby takes off you end up
having like punk rock Bruce who puts the
tape into his tape player because you
know I guess if you're outside of the
system you don't listen to mp3 so he
listens to the tape higher and and
basically like the punk rock music
brings out like punk rock whole and let
me tell you something
he looks badass he's got like a metal
tattoo on his arm he's like a man
hardcore I'll be honest man I want to
see more of like punk fork like I want I
just don't even want to see an ongoing
series like a miniseries just give me
like a mini series that like like punk
Hulk vol 1 and it's just like give me
the origin of his character I want it
like I want to read that story cuz like
that seems so cool I love the incredible
whole everybody loves incredible and
like The Incredible Hulk smashing people
like listening to like sublime I don't
practice Santeria ain't got no Christian
stuff it'd be pretty awesome he'd be
pretty beast but yeah like this this was
a kind of force that like spider punk
needed to take out came to conquer
because much like the main model
University credible Hulk he's just like
sure unrivaled rage and that stands to
reason right like the incredible which
one of those characters you don't really
change you can a little bit but you have
to have introduced a new character to
pull it off like Red Hulk or like red
she-hulk
or she-hulk herself or something along
those lines when it comes to like the
tried and true standard Incredible Hulk
it's generally accepted super strength
and you know super durability and like
you know strengthen increases with rage
and like a healing factor and just like
by just an absolute force of nature is
what the Incredible Hulk has to
any deviation from that and people get
pissed so like you you can't really care
really like mess it up mess it up and
screw around with it too much but again
like Kings defeated quite readily
at which point Spider Punk is met by the
arrival spider woman and she's like hey
so uh like we have a problem again and
we kind of need to team up in order to
take care of it now here's the important
thing is there's a passing comment
that's made by King and he basically
says you hoby died at a very young age
and the implication here is that homie
will actually die during the events of
spider again so it is kind of kind of
cool
in reality this story felt like it was
written just for the sake of having it
written and that was really about it but
it does work and it's not really a great
big huge deal so of course he ends up
citing and says yeah sure man let's go
for one last ride and jumps into the
portal and then whisks into wherever it
takes him presumably alongside the rest
of the spiders during the events have
spider again but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]